[Music]
today we're gonna put in more of the
framing for the wall if these side
little things that bump out we're gonna
frame goes all up that's gonna start
tightening up all the framing on the
house and tomorrow we're gonna have the
loft put in which will really keep it
all tight together so Jacob told me I'm
gonna be his cut goddess today I have to
cut these ribs for all the way around
this so this will be my day heavy piece
of plywood that goes up makes it locked
in perfect excellent good we're nailing
all day my arms are killing me
I'm really glad this is the last law
because I actually can't take any more
of this it's gun is heavy for me we only
have the whole entire roof to do
there's about twice as much roof I'm
scared of heights so no are you gonna
stack a ladder on a ladder for that one
again or no what you heard me
[Music]
my mom and stepdad just showed up to
help us at cabin lands and they just got
here and we already put them to work
we really want to use a lot of the
materials that are in these cabins we're
gonna get their help
salvaging all of that here's where we're
gonna start with the whole salvaging
thing see she's already found something
a container can we say that should we
use it
see nice you're a lot like me in that
way waste not one at all
we're gonna start though with salvaging
all these shingles off here even these
wet ones I just have so much life and
I'm still these shingles are amazing
when you're salvaging shingles you start
at the top course and since the shingles
went up from bottom to top they come off
from top to bottom and then we'll have a
nice big stack of shingles that we can
use these boards right here are like
really nice you know like these look
like easy enough to come to pull I don't
want to see what's inside this this
could be the wall of the cabin on the
inside so essentially we've got like the
exterior siding on from that cabin the
interior wall material we can get mostly
from this cabin and even the siding
there is probably shiplap cedar yeah we
can't even get in I'll have to come out
here with a chainsaw and cut this tree
up hey there's some chairs in here mom
that chair is mold all over you wash it
back tables you're not like a hoarder
you're like a picker this is like
American Pickers right I love folk and
rainforests Hey look a bowl while
they're salvaging we're gonna be out
there still working on the cabin getting
it ready we're gonna be bringing in the
windows and the ceiling which is like a
big process
yeah really old I mean it's a lot of
work care and all these cabins up but
you can't buy this stuff here we need
this gusting nothing wrong with it
oh my goodness this is a Moss man's
dream
we're up here on the roof we've got this
insane moss in these ferns we got
multiple kinds of ferns this is like an
established forest over here with sword
ferns we're gonna save this moss the
best way to do it is just to slide your
hand under it to try to keep it together
as much as possible it just peels right
off and look at that man
and we just roll it up like a carpet and
like one big piece that's rolling really
nice are you killing the ferns right now
when you're rolling them up I never in
my administration have I condone fern
killing we're gonna take this down and
we're gonna unroll it again yeah so it
can grow right and it can live and it
can breathe until we need it we can live
with that okay we have so much wood
we're super stoked because Cathy and
Stan have been making us rich in lumber
and shingles she even organized it into
like wit we've got 1 by 6 1 by 4 1 by 8
it's like a lumber yard here take these
flat flat nails I've been working pool
yes
yes I expire at a certain point you know
everything you're doing is super super
helpful it's fun I like it are you
having fun I like helping you guys nice
thank you you're huge Oh
so last night I made all the cuts for
the loft floor we're gonna lay down the
floorboards make sure that they all fit
screw them in and then move on to the
next thing
on your marks get set go she's a fierce
competitor we have a loft we have a loft
it's amazing what do you think this is
what it's gonna be like you're on your
queen size man and they're like this and
hopefully rains not falling on your face
[Music]
my ass is soaked good luck oh there is
an old stove in here an old wood stove
that's so cool
oh man an old couch another TV all
another show that's cool
you want to push hard you don't want to
go to your mom's air B&B and watch an
entire Netflix series on Ted Bundy do I
want to do that yes
should we no okay
[Music]
get over here you know that is babe
obviously
oh my gosh this is the best day ever
today we rented an excavator and we have
to tear all these down which I'm so
excited to start cleaning up this
property this feels so good to start
knocking down these old creepy cabins
and it's like snowing today so it feels
like Christmas we're not actually
getting anything or getting rid of stuff
look at this it actually feels romantic
because I've thought and dreamt about
this day for so long these things are
everywhere man
everywhere one down there's like 35 to
go what'd you find
stove your favorite color too ugly
orange oh this is sketchy oh my god if
my ear I'm coming off scream we should
leave a little bit suitum punch it you
love punching the window I do now I'm
gonna go inside and punch the [ __ ] out
of this window I'm gonna get up in here
and just because it makes them feel
strong but he's really not doing
anything 230 cut oh my gosh why would
you tell everyone that before I did it
at least give him a second of thinking
I'm strong not that heavy
oh did you ask them to save this that
takes salvaging to a whole new level are
you sure there's not a step no that's
not too bad equality there's no way yes
what about some old what about this Isis
[Music]
we are to the point where 95% of the
sheathing is on this thing is rock solid
a giant could pick this thing up roll it
down a hill and it would maintain its
shape nothing would change it's solid as
a rock
before we put on the shingles and the
trim and all the roofing material we got
to put on the vapor barrier and that's
what she's doing right now this is like
a surgical glove right here you don't
need any more coffee
we've had enough coffee
I could feel it seeping into my skin
through my face in my pores help I do
will you help me
[Music]
all right so I'm attaching the trim
right now these are the board's that
Cathy and Stan got from inside one of
the shacks over there
Sarah's sanding it now she's just
kissing it with the palm sander
that means she's just taken off the dirt
and a little bit of the surface that's
how you take some old salvaged wood from
a junky creepy old cabin and you turn it
into something beautiful yes yes unlike
the town quieter cabin land come one
come all
cabin laminates have a ball from near
and far from far in air come to cabin
land my dear
so for the past three days Cathy and
Stan have been busting their humps
salvaging while we've been building and
it's time to take a break and go to the
beach everything you guys have done I've
been there
here for this one you guys
see it when it's all done Oh God city oh
yeah all that Salvage material put to
work it's looking so good
[Music]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please